away from the front lines it's Ukraine's
other battle that could impact the
outcome in this war the fight against
chronic corruption there is some sort of
institutional inertia that you cannot
just easily overcome within a like like
within a couple of years and then say
that it's
over ason Jad dof heads a new agency
designed to make defense procurement
more efficient there's been a series of
broad scandals involving military
contracts the government says it's
determined to tackle corruption to make
Ukraine more acceptable to its overseas
backers we understand that this war is
about values we understand that these
values they are certainly
about uh making the government
accountable to its citizens not the
other way
round and the billions of dollars in
military aid Ukraine receives from
overseas is quickly being matched by
billions more for
reconstruction the task of tackling
corruption is made all the more urgent
given the massive effort that will be
needed to rebuild Ukraine after this war
earlier this year on the first
anniversary of the invasion the price
tag for Recovery was put at more than
$400 billion giving a sense of the scale
of rebuilding that will be needed when
the guns fall silent when uh Civil
Society organizations are exposing
corruption is proving that there is
anti-corruption fight in Ukraine
happening right now despite that there
is large scale Invasion and at that
moment Daria kuk has been campaigning
against corruption for more than a
decade and sees change happening driven
in part she believes by Ukraine's move
to be internationally accepted uh the
next step of the EU negotiations about
membership uh will open up the new
package of Leverage for us for civil
society to and and for our government to
deliver reforms and also the perspective
of NATO membership for many here success
in this war will be measured not only on
the battlefield but in the kind of civil
society that emerges from it Rob McBride
Al jazer ke